Raising children can be particularly challenging these days. There are dozens of books and articles offering competing answers to nearly every parenting question you might have, from how to get your baby to sleep, to how to help siblings get along, to how much screen time is too much, to whether to let your tween attend a sleepover. Meanwhile, every parenting decision you make,
如今，养育孩子可能特别具有挑战性。市面上有几十本书和文章，对你可能遇到的几乎每一个育儿问题都给出了相互矛盾的答案，从如何让婴儿入睡，到如何帮助兄弟姐妹和睦相处，再到屏幕时间多少才算过多，以及是否应该让你的青春期前孩子参加过夜派对。与此同时，你所做的每一个育儿决定，
even the most mundane ones, can feel consequential. It's no wonder that many parents feel tired, stressed, stressed, and unsure of whether they're doing a good job. In a recent Pew Research Center survey, 47% of mothers and 34% of fathers said they felt that parenting was tiring most or all of the time, and one-third of mothers and one-quarter of fathers felt it was stressful all or most of the time. So as a parent, how do you know which of your choices matter most and where to focus your limited parenting energy?
即使是最琐碎的决定，也可能感觉影响深远。难怪许多父母感到疲惫、压力重重，并且不确定自己是否做得好。在皮尤研究中心最近的一项调查中，47%的母亲和34%的父亲表示，他们感到育儿在大部分或全部时间里都是令人疲惫的，三分之一的母亲和四分之一的父亲感到育儿在所有或大部分时间里都是令人压力的。那么作为父母，你如何知道哪些选择最重要，以及应该将有限的育儿精力集中在哪里？
What's the right balance between keeping kids safe and giving them freedom? How should you respond when your kids try your patience with whining, sibling fights, or teenage sarcasm? How should your parenting change as your kids get older? And most important, how can you develop a loving, supportive relationship with your children that will stand the test of time and lead to a happy, well-adjusted family? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
在保护孩子安全和给予他们自由之间，正确的平衡点在哪里？当孩子用哭闹、兄弟姐妹间的争吵或青少年的讽刺来考验你的耐心时，你应该如何应对？随着孩子长大，你的育儿方式应该如何改变？最重要的是，你如何才能与孩子建立一种充满爱、相互支持的关系，这种关系能够经受住时间的考验，并带来一个幸福、适应良好的家庭？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
We have two guests today. They are the authors of a new book published by the American Psychological Association called Good Enough Parenting, a six-point plan for a stronger relationship with your child. First is Dr. Tim Cavell, a professor in the Department of Psychological Science at the University of Arkansas, and a practicing psychologist. Dr. Cavell's research focuses on parent- and mentor-based interventions for children. at risk, including programs for aggressive children and chronically bullied children. Dr. Cavell is also published more than 60 research articles and chapters, as well as several
今天我们有两位嘉宾。他们是美国心理学会出版的一本新书的作者，书名是《足够好的育儿：与孩子建立更牢固关系的六点计划》。第一位是阿肯色大学心理科学系教授、执业心理学家蒂姆·卡维尔博士。卡维尔博士的研究重点是针对高危儿童的基于父母和导师的干预措施，包括针对攻击性儿童和长期受欺凌儿童的项目。卡维尔博士还发表了60多篇研究文章和章节，以及几本
books for clinicians who work with at-risk kids and their families. He's also the father of three children who are now in the 20s and 30s. Our second guest today is Dr. Lauren Quetch, also a professor in the Department of Psychological Science at the University of Arkansas and a licensed clinical psychologist. Her work focuses on children with disruptive behavior and autism spectrum disorder, and in particular, helping parents of children with autism build stronger parent-child relationships. She also works with community mental health agencies in an effort to help families get access to evidence-based treatments faster. Dr. Quetch is the mother of four young children.
为与高危儿童及其家庭工作的临床医生撰写的书籍。他也是三个现在已经二十多岁和三十多岁孩子的父亲。我们今天的第二位嘉宾是劳伦·奎奇博士，她也是阿肯色大学心理科学系的教授，同时是一位持证临床心理学家。她的工作重点是患有破坏性行为和自闭症谱系障碍的儿童，特别是帮助自闭症儿童的父母建立更牢固的亲子关系。她还与社区心理健康机构合作，努力帮助家庭更快地获得循证治疗。奎奇博士是四个年幼孩子的母亲。
Dr. Cavells and Dr. Quetch's book aims to help the parents of children from toddlers to teens learn practical, science-based strategies to build healthy and lasting parent-child relationships. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you for having me. Good to be here. Let's start with the title of the book and why you chose it. What does it mean to be a good enough parent, and why should parents aim for good enough as opposed to spectacular or out of this world?
卡维尔博士和奎奇博士的书旨在帮助从幼儿到青少年的父母学习实用的、基于科学的策略，以建立健康且持久的亲子关系。感谢你们两位今天加入我的节目。谢谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。让我们从书名以及你们为什么选择这个书名开始谈起。成为一个“足够好的父母”意味着什么？为什么父母应该追求“足够好”，而不是“壮观”或“超凡脱俗”？
We must concede that the term was borrowed. The phrase, good enough mother, was coined back in the 50s by a psychologist named Donald Winnicott. And the phrase, good enough parenting has been around for quite a while. In fact, you could probably find two or three books with similar titles that might invoke the term good enough or good enough parenting. It's interesting if you look at the history of one of the caught's use of the term because he thought that the perfect parent was less effective than the good enough parent. And what he meant by that was that the good enough parent doesn't always meet every child's need. In fact, he used the term fail. Sometimes they fail to meet their child's every need.
我们必须承认这个术语是借用来的。“足够好的母亲”这个短语是由一位名叫唐纳德·温尼科特的心理学家在50年代提出的。而“足够好的育儿”这个短语已经存在相当长一段时间了。事实上，你可能能找到两三本标题类似的书，它们可能都引用了“足够好”或“足够好的育儿”这个术语。如果你回顾温尼科特使用这个术语的历史，会很有趣，因为他认为完美的父母不如足够好的父母有效。他的意思是，足够好的父母并不总是能满足孩子的所有需求。事实上，他用了“失败”这个词。有时他们确实无法满足孩子的所有需求。
And in so doing, children learn to cope on their own. And we think that's an important message for today's parent because there's tons of information. To me, it feels like a weight to try to be a good parent. It seems that if the bar has been set to perfect or at least quote unquote effective, and we wanted to write a book that describes in a more holistic fashion, what it means to be a parent that's going to do what matters most and not wear yourself out in the process or not become a hyper-hover parent as well. Yeah, I think when we were talking about this and trying to decide on this title as well, you know, I have four young kids. And one of the
通过这样做，孩子们学会了独立应对。我们认为这对今天的父母来说是一个重要的信息，因为现在信息量太大了。对我来说，试图成为一个完美的父母感觉像是一种负担。如果标准被设定为完美，或者至少是所谓的“有效”，那似乎太沉重了。我们想写一本书，以一种更全面的方式描述成为父母意味着什么，即做最重要的事情，而不是在这个过程中耗尽自己，或者成为一个过度干预的父母。是的，我想当我们讨论这个问题并试图确定这个标题时，你知道，我有四个年幼的孩子。而且其中
things that I've been involved in, I have, there's a group of a few mothers that graduated from my PhD program. And we all sort of lean on each other for parenting advice, if you will. And what ends up happening, what I've realized is a lot of what can be consumed about parenting is sets the bar really high to the point of if I do something wrong, what does that mean for my child? My child is going to fail in life. And this, I've noticed, has created a really high amount of anxiety for new parents in this generation. And I think it has really helped to talk to them and sort of back. bounce ideas off of each other, but also recognize that some of the things that we say are,
我参与的一件事是，我有一群从我的博士项目中毕业的母亲。我们都在育儿建议上互相依靠。最终发生的事情，我意识到的是，关于育儿的很多信息把标准定得太高了，以至于如果我做错了什么，那对我的孩子意味着什么？我的孩子会在生活中失败吗？我注意到，这给这一代的新手父母带来了极大的焦虑。我认为，与他们交谈并互相交流想法，同时也认识到我们所说的一些事情是，
you know, really important. Like, you know, how does my kid look today? Or maybe did I not handle this situation exactly right? Comes down to, well, sometimes it's okay to just be good enough. Because if we worry too much about all of the fine details, kind of like what was Tim was talking about is we miss the larger picture of what it means to be a parent and what it means to run a family. And so good enough, I think is often now the advice that parents need more than ever because they're told so many things about you have to be this way and a perfect parent looks like this and it's just too much. It's too much to manage. Can I add to that? Because I agree wholeheartedly with what Lauren said. And I think our book aims for a sweet spot between, you know,
你知道，真的很重要。比如，我的孩子今天看起来怎么样？或者也许我处理这种情况的方式不太对？归根结底，有时“足够好”就可以了。因为如果我们太担心所有的细节，就像蒂姆所说的那样，我们就会忽略成为父母和经营家庭的更宏大的图景。所以，“足够好”我认为是现在父母比以往任何时候都更需要的建议，因为他们被告知了太多关于“你必须这样”、“完美的父母看起来是这样的”之类的话，这实在太多了。这太难应付了。我可以补充一点吗？因为我完全同意劳伦所说的。我认为我们的书旨在寻找一个最佳平衡点，你知道，
there's one kind of parenting book that's a rather foxy, homespun approach to parenting. It's more of a literary work than a reflection of the science of parenting. Then there are those books that are drawn tightly from the science of parenting, but those can get rather prescriptive and exacting. And we were, our book, I think, is aimed sort of between the two at a sweet spot, which says, let's build from, let's draw from the science of parenting, but let's render it in a way that's user-friendly, that's parent-friendly, that's digestible, and that distills the key findings down to an essential whole, to what matters most. Does the good enough approach, in effect, also extend to the,
有一种育儿书是那种相当通俗、朴实的育儿方法。它更像是一部文学作品，而不是对育儿科学的反映。还有一些书是紧扣育儿科学的，但那些书可能会变得相当教条和苛刻。而我们的书，我认为，旨在介于两者之间，寻找一个最佳平衡点，它说：让我们借鉴育儿科学，但以一种用户友好、父母友好、易于消化、并将关键发现提炼成一个本质整体的方式来呈现，即关注最重要的事情。“足够好”的方法是否实际上也延伸到了
kids because, you know, there's so much pressure on our children these days to be absolutely perfect and spectacular. So if you're good enough parent, well, maybe you can be a good enough son or daughter as well. Absolutely. I think sometimes people don't realize that when you set standards really high for yourself or for your child, like, I want my child to be the greatest athlete there ever was. Right. And now I know what it means. That means they need to be involved in three sports that take up all their time and the AP classes. They need to be. They need to need to be involved in all of those because my child's going to be the best. And what ends up happening is the child gets burnt out. The parent can get burnt out. And when you base your family
孩子身上？因为，你知道，如今我们的孩子承受着巨大的压力，要变得绝对完美和壮观。所以如果你是一个足够好的父母，嗯，也许你也可以成为一个足够好的儿子或女儿。绝对是这样。我认为有时人们没有意识到，当你为自己或孩子设定极高的标准时，比如，“我希望我的孩子成为有史以来最伟大的运动员”。对吧。现在我知道这意味着什么了。这意味着他们需要参加三项占用他们所有时间的运动，还要上大学预修课程。他们需要成为。他们需要参与所有这些活动，因为我的孩子要成为最好的。最终发生的事情是孩子精疲力竭。父母也会精疲力竭。当你把你的家庭
and your relationship off of those accomplishments, rather than the relationship you actually have with one another, you lose something in there. And that can cause more distress, rather than just focusing on, again, what matters most, the good enough. Yeah, and I think it's been way overstated that our parenting shapes our children and their personality and their future. There are a lot of other factors besides parenting practices that shape who children become. And more recent research speaks loudly to that. And as a parent, And my tendency is to adopt a posture of discovery. Let me discover who my children will become.
和你们的关系建立在这些成就之上，而不是你们之间实际拥有的关系之上时，你就会失去一些东西。这可能会导致更多的痛苦，而不是仅仅专注于，再次强调，最重要的事情，即“足够好”。是的，我认为我们的育儿方式塑造了我们的孩子、他们的个性和他们的未来，这种说法被严重夸大了。除了育儿实践之外，还有许多其他因素塑造了孩子成为什么样的人。最近的研究有力地证明了这一点。作为一名父母，我的倾向是采取一种“发现”的姿态。让我去发现我的孩子将成为什么样的人。
And let me be ready to love and accept them when I discover who they are. But the notion that I'm exercising my preferences and shaping who they are and who they become is both mythical and dangerous. So it's an interesting posture to adopt, but I think it's a healthy one. Let me learn who my child is. let me learn who my child will become, and let me practice accepting who that child is and conveying a message of love and belonging. That's a different way to go about the task of parenting. And I think that that segues into the question that I had where you write about the most important
让我准备好去爱和接纳他们，当我发现他们是谁的时候。但是，我正在行使我的偏好并塑造他们是谁以及他们成为什么样的人，这种观念既是神话又是危险的。所以这是一个有趣的姿态，但我认为这是一个健康的姿态。让我了解我的孩子是谁，让我了解我的孩子将成为什么样的人，让我练习接纳那个孩子是谁，并传达爱和归属感的信息。这是一种不同的育儿任务方式。我认为这引出了我之前的问题，即你们写道，父母最重要的
job that parents have is to build a relationship with their children. And I think that might surprise some people maybe who don't think that they need to build a relationship because they have a relationship. But what do you mean? What is the special approach that you recommend that might not be immediately evident to a harried mother or father? So I believe that we've got core components that we highlight within this book. There are three aspects that we believe are really important for a relationship between a parent and a child. And then we also have some components that we feel are sort of the foundations of those things too. So largely when we're thinking about a relationship, which Tim alluded to already previously, was this
工作是与孩子建立关系。我认为这可能会让一些人感到惊讶，也许他们认为自己不需要建立关系，因为他们已经有了关系。但你们是什么意思？你们推荐的这种特殊方法，对于一个忙碌的母亲或父亲来说，可能不是显而易见的？所以我相信我们在本书中强调了核心组成部分。我们认为对于父母和孩子之间的关系，有三个方面是非常重要的。然后我们还有一些我们认为也是这些事情基础的组成部分。所以，当我们思考关系时，正如蒂姆之前已经提到的，主要是这种
posture of acceptance. So when we think about our relationship with our child, we're really saying, I see you and I accept who you are for who you are, right? So I have four little children and I may parent them pretty similarly. You know, they're all close and age together. as well. And they are different. They're different people. They have different interests. They have different inclinations. They have different temperaments. And so part of being a parent then is first saying, I see that you are who you are and I'm okay with that. And that can look in many different ways. It can be very outward in the way that we express that. And it can also be more silent in the way that we express that too. So sometimes not saying anything.
接纳的姿态。所以当我们思考与孩子的关系时，我们实际上是在说：我看见你，我接纳你本来的样子，对吧？所以我有四个年幼的孩子，我可能以非常相似的方式养育他们。你知道，他们的年龄都很接近。而且他们是不同的人。他们是不同的人。他们有不同的兴趣。他们有不同的倾向。他们有不同的气质。所以作为父母的一部分，首先要说：我看到你就是你，我对此没问题。这可以以许多不同的方式表现出来。它可以非常外向地表达，也可以更沉默地表达。所以有时什么都不说，
and rather than correcting your child all the time. The second component of that then is containing. So thinking about our job as a parent is also to recognize that we, you know, children are impulsive sometimes. We still have to welcome them into the culture and society in which we live and tell them what is and is not acceptable. And so our practices of containment sort of help us do that. And then the last component within that is being a leader and your leadership within the family. So outwardly expressing what it means to be a good person, talking about what our values are within a family, and then sharing that with our children too. There's more to that and I'll let Tim take over.
而不是一直纠正你的孩子。那么第二个组成部分就是“约束”。所以思考我们作为父母的工作，也是要认识到我们，你知道，孩子们有时是冲动的。我们仍然必须欢迎他们进入我们生活的文化和社会，并告诉他们什么是可以接受的，什么是不可以接受的。所以我们的约束实践在某种程度上帮助我们做到这一点。然后其中的最后一个组成部分是作为领导者，以及你在家庭中的领导地位。所以外在地表达成为一个好人意味着什么，谈论我们在家庭中的价值观是什么，然后也与我们的孩子分享这些。这还有更多内容，我会让蒂姆接手。
Yeah. I think if we zoom back a little bit, I think there needs to be an appreciation. that we have cast, we being mainly professionals like Lauren and I, have tended to cast parenting as something set apart from relationships. There are some parenting advice that's like an itemized list of if your child does X, you should do Y. If your child has this problem or engages in this behavior and this is how you should respond without appreciating the context of the relationship in which those events occur. You know, depending on how strong or strained the relationship is, you might want to do very different things because at the end of the day, it's the relationship
是的。我认为如果我们稍微退后一点，我认为需要有一种认识。我们已经把育儿——我们主要是像劳伦和我这样的专业人士——倾向于把育儿看作是与关系分开的东西。有些育儿建议就像是一份逐项列出的清单：如果你的孩子做了X，你应该做Y。如果你的孩子有这个问题或从事这种行为，你应该如何回应，而没有考虑到这些事件发生的关系背景。你知道，根据关系的牢固程度或紧张程度，你可能想做非常不同的事情，因为归根结底，是关系
that will move your child toward being a good, healthy citizen. And I tend to say it this way, Kim, if there was some farcical choice I had to make between two surrogate parents, one who was very good at relationships in his or her life, and one who knew a lot about parenting, I would choose the one who was good at relationships. Because that's what it is. But too often, I think because of people like us throwing out so much advice, folks become parents and they move into this mode where they sort of jettison what they think about in terms of how to make a relationship work. None of the relationships we have should involve being victimized, taking advantage of being abused. None of the relationships we have should involve not trying to convey a message of acceptance to the people we love and care about.
才会推动你的孩子成为一个优秀的、健康的公民。我倾向于这样说，金，如果我必须在两个代孕父母之间做出某种荒谬的选择，一个是生活中非常擅长处理关系的人，另一个是非常了解育儿知识的人，我会选择那个擅长处理关系的人。因为这就是它的本质。但太频繁了，我认为因为像我们这样的人抛出了太多的建议，人们成为父母后，他们进入了一种模式，他们抛弃了关于如何让关系运作的想法。我们拥有的任何关系都不应该涉及被欺负、被占便宜、被虐待。我们拥有的任何关系都不应该涉及不去向我们爱和关心的人传达接纳的信息。
And none of the relationships we have should involve abandoning what our core values are, how we carry ourselves. So you want to bring all those relationship components to the parent-child relationship, not just because it's a parent-child relationship, because that's what it means to have a healthy relationship. Yeah, at the beginning of the book, you asked parents to think about their parenting goals, which are not the same as the goals that they might have for their children's future. What do you mean when you talk about parenting goals? How should parents set them and how can they stick to them? That's a great question. We describe parenting goals as the goals parents have for guiding their parenting behavior.
我们拥有的任何关系都不应该涉及放弃我们的核心价值观，以及我们如何为人处世。所以你想把所有这些关系的组成部分带入亲子关系中，不仅仅是因为它是亲子关系，而是因为这就是拥有健康关系的意义所在。是的，在书的开头，你们要求父母思考他们的育儿目标，这与他们对孩子未来的目标不同。当你们谈论育儿目标时，你们是什么意思？父母应该如何设定这些目标，以及他们如何坚持这些目标？这是一个很好的问题。我们将育儿目标描述为父母为指导其育儿行为而设定的目标。
But it's seldom a topic of discussion. What are your parenting goals? Again, we tend to think of it in terms of what we want for our children down. stream. But if you, a parent, a working parent, you go home that evening, you have some goals in mind as a parent. Oftentimes, they're sort of hidden and maybe embedded in automatic reactions to children. Things become sort of mindless and routine. And we may not be forward thinking or conscious about what are we trying to do in these interactions I have with my child. And if there's value in having a relationship where children feel accepted, they are periodically contained.
但这很少成为讨论的话题。你的育儿目标是什么？同样，我们倾向于从我们对孩子未来的期望来考虑。但如果你，一个工作的父母，那天晚上回家，你作为父母心中有一些目标。通常，它们是隐藏的，也许嵌入在对孩子的自动反应中。事情变得有点无意识和常规化。我们可能没有前瞻性，也没有意识到我们在与孩子的这些互动中试图做什么。如果拥有一个孩子感到被接纳的关系是有价值的，他们会定期受到约束。
In other words, there's a message of this you cannot do. And the parent is carrying himself or herself in a way that espouses good values, then those are great goals to guide parenting behavior. Now, will you know the outcome immediately in terms of your children's functioning? No, it's like a plan. It takes time for that to unfold. So the parents, the goals for parenting behavior are more proximal to what we do in any given day or situation. And to add on that, too, when we act automatically, we may be doing ourselves harm in that relationship. And so thinking about our goal as just having a stronger relationship with our child rather than worrying about who they're going to be or are they the smartest kid in the class?
换句话说，有一个“这个你不能做”的信息。而且父母以一种推崇良好价值观的方式行事，那么这些就是指导育儿行为的伟大目标。现在，你会立即知道孩子表现方面的结果吗？不，这就像一个计划。这需要时间来展开。所以育儿行为的目标更接近于我们在任何特定的一天或情况下所做的事情。而且还要补充一点，当我们自动行事时，我们可能会在那种关系中伤害自己。所以把我们的目标仅仅看作是与孩子建立更牢固的关系，而不是担心他们将来会成为谁，或者他们是否是班上最聪明的孩子？
are they the best athlete? Are they the best dressed? Are they going to be, you know, X, Y, and Z? That may snap in as an automatic goal that you're not thinking about where you're snarky with your kid or you're telling them what they need to be doing. And that sort of forces your hand sometimes to say, how hard am I going to push? If my kid isn't doing what I want them to do right now, I may be pushing an agenda I'm not even aware of consciously at the expense of the relationship that I have with my child. And so if my goal is maybe I'm struggling with a relationship with my child right now. So if my goal, if I'm conscious about I care about my child feeling loved and wanting them to love me back too. Obviously you can't make your child do anything in that way.
他们是最好的运动员吗？他们穿得最好吗？他们会成为，你知道，X、Y和Z吗？这可能会成为一个自动的目标，你并没有意识到，当你对孩子尖酸刻薄，或者告诉他们需要做什么时。这有时会迫使你不得不说：我要推得有多紧？如果我的孩子现在没有做我想要他们做的事情，我可能正在推动一个我甚至没有意识到的议程，而牺牲了我与孩子之间的关系。所以如果我的目标是，也许我目前正在努力改善与孩子的关系。所以如果我的目标，如果我有意识地关注我关心我的孩子感到被爱，并希望他们也爱我。显然你不能强迫你的孩子做任何事情。
you can't force them to love you. And yet if you have that goal, I want us to be stronger together and you're more thoughtful about it. That can change how you act in a moment. And so cleaning up the floor or addressing the tone in which they spoke back to you may seem like that's the most important thing if we're thinking automatically in that moment. But if we say my relationship is the most important, our relationship together is the most important. Then maybe you let some of those things go. and that actually ends up building that relationship stronger. Yeah, it's being intentional, deliberate, and explicit with why you're doing what you're doing as a parent, as opposed to reacting out of some hidden emotional goal, like I'm frustrated or I'm tired,
你不能强迫他们爱你。然而，如果你有那个目标，“我希望我们在一起更强大”，并且你对此更深思熟虑。这可以改变你在那一刻的行为。所以清理地板或纠正他们回话的语气，如果我们在那一刻自动思考，可能看起来是最重要的事情。但如果我们说“我的关系是最重要的，我们在一起的关系是最重要的”。那么也许你会放过其中一些事情。而这实际上最终会使那种关系变得更牢固。是的，这就是作为父母要意图明确、深思熟虑且显性地表达你为什么要做你正在做的事情，而不是出于某种隐藏的情感目标（比如我感到沮丧或疲惫）而做出反应，
or out of some preference to live vicariously through your child. And we offer to parents that, you know, useful goals to keep in mind, or conveying a message of acceptance, conveying a message of containment that there are some things you cannot do, and then conveying a message of what our family values, what we believe in and hold dear. So let me pick up from what you've just said, because you're talking about containment rather than discipline. And in the book, you offer a rule of thumb. You call it the 80-20 rule. What is that and how does that work? So we make the provocative point. that effective discipline is selective discipline.
或者出于某种想通过孩子来实现自己未竟愿望的偏好。我们向父母提供，你知道，值得记住的有用目标，即传达接纳的信息、传达约束的信息（即有些事情你不能做），然后传达我们的家庭价值观、我们信仰和珍视的东西的信息。那么让我从你们刚才所说的接下去，因为你们谈论的是约束而不是纪律。在书中，你们提供了一个经验法则。你们称之为“80-20法则”。那是什么，它是如何运作的？所以我们提出了一个挑衅性的观点：有效的纪律是选择性的纪律。
Okay? Now, there's a lot of science on inept, what Jerry Patterson and colleagues at Oregon Social Learning Center used to call inept discipline with children whose behavior was disruptive and defiant. And the pattern that was observed in these parents was of two sorts, either being quite harsh and overly punitive
好吗？现在，关于无效纪律有很多科学研究，杰里·帕特森和俄勒冈社会学习中心的同事们过去称之为针对行为具有破坏性和反抗性的儿童的“无效纪律”。在这些父母身上观察到的模式有两种，要么是非常严厉和过度惩罚，
or being quite lax and permissive. permissive, okay, not unlike, you know, Balmran's distinction. So, and it makes sense if you're a parent who's having trouble controlling your child's behavior, then you might wax and weighing between being permissive and harsh, harsh and permissive. And so it can be countered by having clarity about, well, what are the things that matter most? What are the things that you want to be consistent on in terms of being?
要么是非常松懈和放任。放任，好吗，这与鲍姆林德的区分没什么不同。所以，如果你是一个在控制孩子行为方面遇到困难的父母，那么你可能会在放任和严厉、严厉和放任之间摇摆不定。因此，通过明确什么是最重要的，什么是你想在纪律方面保持一致的事情，可以抵消这一点。
disciplinarian. And what things do you let go? Sometimes it's said in the parenting literature, Kim, is choose your battles wisely, right? It's a very common phrase. It's a bit unfortunate that the word battle is in there, but nonetheless, the point about choosing wisely is well, well-founded. But it's not often talked about, like, well, what does that mean, you know, choose your battle wisely? Well, we think that the science of parenting points us in a direction there in developmental psychology. One of the behaviors that is most problematic for children's development is their use of coercion, which is a broad term used to define various forms of aggression or antagonistic or threatening behavior. Okay, children who learn to use coercion, aggression, and other sorts of antagonistic behavior are at risk for a lot of problems downstream.
哪些事情你放手？在育儿文献中，金，有时会说：明智地选择你的战斗，对吧？这是一个非常常见的短语。虽然“战斗”这个词在里面有点不幸，但尽管如此，关于明智选择的观点是很有根据的。但人们并不经常谈论，比如，好吧，那意味着什么，你知道，“明智地选择你的战斗”？嗯，我们认为育儿科学在发展心理学中为我们指明了方向。对儿童发展最成问题的行为之一是他们对“强制”的使用，这是一个广泛的术语，用于定义各种形式的攻击性或对抗性或威胁性行为。好吗？学会使用强制、攻击和其他对抗性行为的孩子，在未来面临很多问题的风险。
School dropout, delinquency, substance use, things like that. And so clearly this is a category that matters most, that matters a lot. So if you're looking for where to put your time and energy, it makes sense to put your time and energy on limiting your child's use of coercion and aggression. Now, there are a whole host of other things that matter little to children's development. I think we give an example in the book of bacon eating. What if your daughter was eating bacon and only bacon? And just it persisted. And you said, well, you've got to eat something else.
辍学、犯罪、药物滥用等等。所以很明显，这是一个最重要的类别，非常重要。所以如果你正在寻找把时间和精力放在哪里，把时间和精力放在限制孩子使用强制和攻击上是有意义的。现在，还有一大堆对儿童发展影响很小的事情。我想我们在书中举了一个吃培根的例子。如果你的女儿在吃培根，而且只吃培根？它持续存在。你说，好吧，你必须吃点别的东西。
And that's all she ate. So at what point does bacon eating rise to a significant problem? It might take a while before that's a significant problem or nose speaking or whatever. there's a lot of things that we as parents can prefer that our children not do that we don't we find maybe disgusting or you know unsightly or that it might be annoying but that's very different than saying this behavior if repeated has developmental significance there are not many of those to pay attention to but the ones that are you really want to pay attention to and and here's the kicker if you're going after let's say
而她只吃那个。那么在什么点上，吃培根会上升为一个重大问题？可能需要一段时间才会成为一个重大问题，或者挖鼻孔什么的。有很多我们作为父母可能更希望孩子不要做的事情，我们觉得可能令人作呕，或者，你知道，难看，或者可能很烦人，但这与说“如果这种行为重复出现，具有发展意义”是非常不同的。需要注意的并不多，但那些确实重要的，你真的想注意，而且关键在于：如果你要处理，假设，
hypothetically, 20 different behaviors, only two of which matter. And you're going to be spreading thin your efforts to discipline and contain and likely fail. And so you actually dilute your authority. You dilute the degree to which children see you as a person of authority because you're not being effective and because you're trying to do too much. Okay. And so you want to preserve your efforts at containment for things that matter most. We actually, some of my research looked at children's beliefs about whether parents and teachers can contain them if there's a conflict and goals. We had a measure in one of the items was something like, you want to go play outside.
20种不同的行为，其中只有两种是重要的。你将会分散你的纪律和约束努力，并且很可能会失败。所以你实际上稀释了你的权威。你稀释了孩子们把你视为权威人物的程度，因为你没有效率，而且因为你试图做太多事情。好吗？所以你想为最重要的事情保留你的约束努力。我们实际上，我的一些研究观察了孩子们关于如果存在冲突和目标时，父母和老师是否能约束他们的信念。我们有一个衡量标准，其中一个项目是这样的：你想去外面玩。
Your mom says you can't go play outside. Can she make you stay inside? So it's an effort to get it. Do children believe that adults are in charge? Well, lo and behold, most kids say yes. they're in charge. But for the kids who doubt that, for the kids who have a low sense of containment, they had high levels of problem behavior, regardless of how well parents discipline. So if children are operating from a belief that I can outwit you, you know, do a turnaround, and I can work
你妈妈说你不能去外面玩。她能让你待在里面吗？所以这是一种试图了解。孩子们是否相信成年人说了算？嗯，你瞧，大多数孩子说是的，他们说了算。但对于那些怀疑这一点的孩子，对于那些约束感很低的孩子，他们有高水平的问题行为，无论父母纪律做得多好。所以如果孩子们基于一种“我可以智胜你，你知道，来个大反转，我可以绕过你”的信念行事，
around you, if they doubt your position of authority, that's not good. And so you want to protect and preserve your position of authority through the use of selective discipline. The other win that comes from that is that you reduce the number of occasions where the interactions are emotionally negative. Because discipline can often involve negative emotionality, unpleasant encounters. So if you reduce the occasions where you're trying to discipline your child to contain your job where there's negative emotions, then guess what happens? Your relationship is more positive than negative. And again, there's pretty consistent research that shows that an 80% or about, four to one ratio of positive or neutral exchanges to negative exchanges is signals a satisfying,
如果你怀疑你的权威地位，那是不好的。所以你想通过使用选择性纪律来保护和维护你的权威地位。由此带来的另一个好处是，你减少了互动中情感负面的次数。因为纪律通常可能涉及负面情绪、不愉快的遭遇。所以如果你减少了试图管教孩子以约束你的工作、存在负面情绪的次数，那么猜猜会发生什么？你的关系是正面多于负面。而且，同样，有相当一致的研究表明，80%左右，即四比一的正面或中性交流与负面交流的比例，标志着一种令人满意的、
stable relationship. If you're a parent who's 50 at 50%, half the time it's negative, half the time it's positive, that's not good. And so the goal would be to kind of use your gut as a barometer. How is my relationship with my child going? Am I experiencing at least 80% or close to it of my interaction? as neutral or positive? And neutral is the key part of that.
稳定的关系。如果你是一个50%的父母，一半时间是负面的，一半时间是正面的，那是不好的。所以目标是把你的直觉当作晴雨表。我与孩子的关系进展如何？我是否至少有80%或接近这个比例的互动是中性或正面的？而中性是其中的关键部分。
Yeah. As it like a coin flip. Like I never know when we're going to be back in the relationship red. Right. And that was beautifully said, Tim. And I think often when we give that figure, you know, it's gone from, it can be four to one, right, that these things are happening as well. But I think people freak out because they say, how am I supposed to, you know, in a society, in American society, where we're like, you've got to be happy. And that's a sign of things working well, right? I think when we start
是的。就像抛硬币一样。就像我永远不知道我们什么时候会回到关系的红色区域。对吧。蒂姆说得太好了。而且我认为当我们给出那个数字时，你知道，它已经从，它可以是四比一，对吧，这些事情也在发生。但我认为人们会吓坏，因为他们说，我怎么能，你知道，在一个社会中，在美国社会中，我们就像，你必须快乐。这是一个事情运作良好的标志，对吧？我认为当我们开始
providing the context of, well, you know, most of the time things should be happy, then I think that also sets up unrealistic expectations. So the important component of that is neutral. Neutral or positive, not in, and so that is in direct contrast with negative. So if you're noticing that the most of the time or even half of the time you're getting into spats or your child is getting frustrated with you and angry with you, then that is usually a problem. But if it's neutral, neutral can be my kid just whined at me when I gave them something, right? We can ignore that. The idea is what do we focus on and what do we care about? And so Tim also was talking about, you know, when there's coercion. It could be lying, stealing, things that do lead to those problem behaviors later on and are more concerning, as we've seen.
提供背景时，嗯，你知道，大多数时候事情应该是快乐的，那么我认为这也设定了不切实际的期望。所以其中的重要组成部分是“中性”。中性或正面，而不是，所以这与负面形成直接对比。所以如果你注意到大多数时候甚至一半的时间你都在争吵，或者你的孩子对你感到沮丧和愤怒，那么这通常是一个问题。但如果是中性的，中性可以是：当我给他们东西时，我的孩子只是对我抱怨，对吧？我们可以忽略这一点。关键是我们关注什么，我们在乎什么？所以蒂姆也谈到了，你知道，当有强制行为时。这可能是撒谎、偷窃，那些确实会导致后来那些问题行为的事情，而且正如我们所见，更令人担忧。
Those are the things that we call, you know, you have to get your butt off the couch for, right? Those are the things we don't ignore. Those are the things we have to stand up and we have to deal with that frustrating confrontation potentially. For young kids, it's, you know, they throw tantrums, they get really angry. I know that all too well. And recognizing those things are important. And some things just aren't worth the time or the energy because it does sacrifice that relationship that what you have with your child. So do I like that my child rolled their eyes at me or, you know, was used a whiny voice or I just cook dinner and now, and no, oh, mom, that's gross. Get that a lot. It's sometimes it's not
那些是我们称之为，你知道，你必须从沙发上站起来去处理的事情，对吧？那些是我们不忽略的事情。那些是我们必须站起来，我们必须处理那种令人沮丧的对抗的事情。对于年幼的孩子，它是，你知道，他们发脾气，他们变得非常愤怒。我太了解这一点了。认识到这些事情很重要。而有些事情只是不值得花费时间和精力，因为它确实牺牲了那种你与孩子拥有的关系。所以我喜欢我的孩子对我翻白眼，或者，你知道，用了抱怨的声音，或者我刚做完晚饭，然后，哦，妈妈，那太恶心了。经常听到这个。有时它不
worth fighting about, right? You let it go, you let it slide. And it's to the benefit of the relationship because of that. And an additional component to that is, you know, when you have a child that is really well behaving, right, so they're not lying, they're not getting into physical altercations with people, you can focus on some of that smaller stuff. You know, if your kid listens to you, I don't know, young kids on average will listen six out of ten times, really little kids, right? That's pretty good if they're listening six out of ten times. And often when kids come in that I've seen that have behavior problems, we're seeing zero out of ten times, two out of ten times, right? And if you've got kids that are really pretty compliant,
值得争吵，对吧？你放手，你让它过去。而且这对关系是有益的。而其中的一个额外组成部分是，你知道，当你有一个表现非常好的孩子时，对吧，所以他们不撒谎，他们不与人发生身体冲突，你可以专注于一些较小的事情。你知道，如果你的孩子听你的话，我不知道，年幼的孩子平均会听十次中的六次，非常小的孩子，对吧？如果他们十次中有六次在听，那已经很不错了。而且通常当孩子们进来时，我看到的有行为问题的孩子，我们看到的是十次中的零次，十次中的两次，对吧？如果你有非常顺从的孩子，
then you can, you know, you can start enforcing some things that maybe other parents that have a more difficult relationship with their child cannot. So, hey, I told you, you know, every time you leave a room, turn off the lights. Or we have this rule where you put your shoes by the front door. Okay. If your kid is a generally happy kid and your relationship is not continuously strained and they're not beating other kids up and lying, then those are the things you can focus on. If you've got a kid that you're having a really hard relationship with and they are lying, they are getting into a lot of fights, there's a lot of verbal issues going on where they're screaming at you, those types of enforcement, those little things are what we should ignore. So it's a tiered system. And we talk about that more in the book, too. I think that you talk about mindful and mindless parenting. And I wanted to talk about the differences between the two.
那么你可以，你知道，你可以开始执行一些其他与孩子关系更困难的父母无法执行的事情。所以，嘿，我告诉过你，你知道，每次你离开房间，关掉灯。或者我们有这个规则，你把鞋子放在前门。好吗。如果你的孩子是一个通常快乐的孩子，你们的关系没有持续紧张，他们没有打其他孩子，也没有撒谎，那么这些就是你可以关注的事情。如果你有一个与你关系非常困难的孩子，他们正在撒谎，他们正在卷入很多争吵，有很多言语问题，他们对你尖叫，那些类型的执行，那些小事情是我们应该忽略的。所以这是一个分层系统。我们在书中也谈到了这一点。我想你们谈到了“正念育儿”和“无意识育儿”。我想谈谈两者之间的区别。
because I think that some of what you're talking about requires a level of mindfulness. But mindless parenting also has a role. And I think, as you say, it's not because the parent is unplugged or inept. But what are some examples of the two and how can parents use those techniques to their advantage? So we don't use the word mindless to mean that someone's being stupid or unwise. It's meant to imply a mental state in which you're operating on automatic in an overlearned automatic way. So you're not deliberate and conscious about what you're doing. Mindful parenting on the other hand, it involves a much more conscious, deliberate, effortful decision about what you're going to do.
因为我认为你们谈论的一些内容需要一定程度的正念。但无意识育儿也有其作用。而且我认为，正如你们所说，这不是因为父母脱节或无能。但这两者的一些例子是什么，父母如何利用这些技巧来发挥他们的优势？所以我们使用“无意识”这个词并不是指某人很愚蠢或不明智。它的意思是暗示一种心理状态，在这种状态下，你以一种过度学习的自动方式运作。所以你对你正在做的事情并不深思熟虑和有意识。另一方面，正念育儿涉及一种更自觉、深思熟虑、费力的关于你将要做什么的决定。
We can't operate that way 24-7. It's impossible, whether it's a parent or anyone. But you can move into that mode at times. The danger is not appreciating that some of your parenting is rather mindless, automatic and overlearned. And so if you keep finding yourself stuck in the same old dynamic of getting crossways with your child and you're both angry and frustrated and sad and hurt, then you might want to consider the possibility that there's some automatic overlearn aspects to your parenting. and it would be important to attend to what it is that you're feeling, experiencing, and thinking as you begin to engage or interact with your child. So we have an entire chapter in our book devoted to health.
我们不能24/7那样运作。这是不可能的，无论是父母还是任何人。但你有时可以进入那种模式。危险在于没有意识到你的一些育儿方式是相当无意识、自动和过度学习的。所以如果你发现自己总是陷入与孩子发生冲突的旧动态中，你们俩都感到愤怒、沮丧、悲伤和受伤，那么你可能想考虑一下你的育儿方式中存在一些自动的过度学习方面的可能性。并且在你开始与孩子接触或互动时，关注你的感受、经历和想法是很重要的。所以我们的书中有一整章专门讨论健康。
We see it as an essential ingredient in parenting, parents' health. And much of that is emotional health. And research in the last two decades has spoken very robustly to the fact that managing our emotional health requires that we can pause. We can hit the pause button psychologically and attend to what's happening inside what we're thinking, what we're feeling, as opposed to reacting rather quickly in an automatic-overlearned way to get rid of whatever unpleasantness we're feeling. Most people cope from the head down in that automatic overlearned way. And we recommend coping, we call from the ground up, getting grounded in the present moment,
我们认为它是育儿的一个基本要素，即父母的健康。其中很大一部分是心理健康。过去二十年的研究非常有力地证明了一个事实，即管理我们的心理健康需要我们能够暂停。我们可以在心理上按下暂停键，关注内心正在发生的事情，我们在想什么，我们在感受什么，而不是为了摆脱我们感受到的任何不快而迅速地以一种自动的、过度学习的方式做出反应。大多数人以那种自动的、过度学习的方式从头到脚地应对。而我们建议应对，我们称之为“从地面向上”，扎根于当下，
paying attention to what you're feeling, and then going to the head with a wise plan. So it's about being aware of, you know, awarenessing as Cabin's in, the person who brought mindfulness into health care would say my awareness thing is biggest than thinking because it subsumes thinking. But a lot of parents don't practice being aware in a zoomed about. fashion of what they're doing. So none of this happens without practice, by the way. So you can't just decide one day to be a mindful parent. It requires that you practice pausing, being in the moment, and leaning into what you're feeling. And we spend an entire chapter unpacking that. Both of you work with kids who have serious behavior issues in your research and in your
注意你的感受，然后带着明智的计划去思考。所以这是关于意识到，你知道，“意识”，正如卡巴金——那个将正念引入医疗保健的人——会说我的意识比思考更重要，因为它包含了思考。但许多父母并没有练习以一种放大的方式去意识到他们正在做的事情。所以顺便说一句，这一切都没有练习是不会发生的。所以你不能仅仅决定有一天成为一个正念的父母。它需要你练习暂停，活在当下，并倾听你的感受。我们花了一整章来剖析这一点。你们两位在你们的研究中与有严重行为问题的孩子一起工作，在你们的
clinical work. Is your advice different for those parents than it is for dealing with run-of-the-mill everyday problems or does the same type of advice apply across the board for all types of families and situations? Dr. Quetch, maybe you could answer first based on your work with disruptive children and those who have autism spectrum disorder. A lot to unpack there, I think, because historically, a lot of the evidence-based treatments that we use to work with families to address disruptive behaviors assumes a lack of skill on the parents' side. So often you will go to a treatment for your child who is experiencing disruptive behaviors and you'll go essentially so that a therapist can teach you possibly what you're missing.
临床工作。对于那些父母，您的建议是否与处理日常琐碎问题的建议不同？还是说同样的建议适用于所有类型的家庭和情况？Quetch博士，也许您可以先根据您在处理破坏性儿童和自闭症谱系障碍儿童方面的工作来回答。我认为这里有很多需要拆解的内容，因为从历史上看，我们用来与家庭合作解决破坏性行为的许多循证治疗方法，都假设父母缺乏技能。所以通常情况下，当您的孩子出现破坏性行为时，您会去寻求治疗，本质上是为了让治疗师教您可能缺失的东西。
It's assumed then my child is misbehaving because of some sort of deficit within the parent. So bad, you know, bad behavior on the child part is sometimes assumed bad parenting, right? And we try to challenge that myth in a way because we say, you can have skills and there may be other things getting in the way of you being able to connect with your child in a meaningful way. So when working with parents of autistic kids, you know, a lot of these parents do have great skills. And they are challenged because they have a neurodivergent child. They don't understand how their child experiences the world. And if they're neurotypical themselves, they think, well, when a child screams and throws a fit, that means they're being defecutive. right and therefore I will approach my child as if they're being defiant and I handle it by providing
人们会认为，我的孩子行为不端是因为父母存在某种缺陷。所以，你知道，孩子的不良行为有时被认为是糟糕的教养方式，对吧？我们试图以某种方式挑战这种迷思，因为我们认为，你可能具备技能，但可能还有其他因素阻碍了你与孩子建立有意义的联系。因此，在与自闭症儿童的父母合作时，你知道，许多父母确实拥有出色的技能。他们面临挑战是因为他们有一个神经多样性的孩子。他们不了解孩子是如何体验世界的。如果他们自己是神经典型者，他们会想，好吧，当孩子尖叫和发脾气时，那意味着他们表现得很叛逆。对吧，因此我会把孩子当作叛逆来对待，并通过提供
you know there's a sanction or I put them in time out or I you know have privileges removed but it's different because sometimes a child is not tantruming because you've told them no but instead they're having a meltdown because they are overstimulated by the sense of their sensory overload in the environment, whether it's noise, light, touch. And so to assume then your child is misbehaving because you lack skills is to neglect this complex, you know, child, this complex parent-child relationship in this environment that a parent may not even understand. So I think we we frame it in a way in this book to understand what Tim had talked about earlier. What are the behaviors that you're seeing and the more intense the behavior is such as lying, aggression,
你知道，某种制裁，或者我让他们暂停活动，或者我你知道，剥夺他们的特权，但这有所不同，因为有时孩子发脾气不是因为你拒绝了他们，而是因为他们因为环境中的感官过载，无论是噪音、光线还是触觉，而感到过度刺激，从而导致崩溃。因此，如果认为孩子行为不端是因为你缺乏技能，那就是忽视了这种复杂的，你知道，孩子，这种复杂的亲子关系，以及父母可能甚至不了解的环境。所以我认为我们在书中以一种方式来构建它，以理解Tim之前谈到的内容。你所看到的行为是什么？行为越强烈，例如撒谎、攻击，
deceitfulness? We need to address that first. And if those things are managed, then you sort of go up this funnel and these less intense behaviors, right, are something then that you can shift your parenting goals towards. But it may look different for families based on their needs, based on the parents' own personal health, the family's health, other circumstances, difficult environments, et cetera. So yes, there are core things that we found to be really important to help sort of lead the child to success, but to say one size fits all for each family or each parent-child relationship is neglecting the complexity of us as people and as a parent and a child together. Dr. Kavell, does that approach work when you're dealing with parents who have children who are bullies or may be bullied?
欺骗？我们需要先解决这些问题。如果这些事情得到了控制，那么你就可以沿着这个漏斗向上走，这些不太强烈的行为，对吧，就是你可以将育儿目标转向的东西。但对于不同的家庭来说，根据他们的需求、父母个人的健康状况、家庭健康、其他环境、困难的环境等，情况可能会有所不同。所以是的，我们发现了一些核心的东西对于帮助引导孩子走向成功非常重要，但要说每个家庭或每个亲子关系都适用同一种方法，那就是忽视了我们作为人，以及作为父母和孩子在一起时的复杂性。Kavell博士，当您处理那些孩子是霸凌者或可能被霸凌的父母时，这种方法有效吗？
I think the conditions necessary for a strong parent-child relationship are similar in terms of what's needed. What's going to differ, Kim, is what's required. of parent depending on their child-rearing circumstances and the characteristic of the child. I mean, the research is pretty clear that children arrive in this world with certain endowments, genetic endowments, which influences their environment. Some children are really easy to parent. Some children are very challenging to parent. And so parents have to fit what they're doing to what their child needs.
我认为建立牢固亲子关系所需的条件在需求方面是相似的。Kim，不同之处在于，根据孩子的教养环境和孩子的特征，父母需要做什么。我的意思是，研究非常清楚地表明，孩子们带着某些天赋，即遗传天赋来到这个世界，这会影响他们的环境。有些孩子很容易抚养。有些孩子抚养起来非常有挑战性。因此，父母必须根据孩子的需求来调整他们的做法。
for children who are easy temperament, meet schedules, they're compliant, cooperative, they're emotionally regulated. Parenting, I think the parent-child relationship is going to have the same three conditions except contain and lead, but parents won't have to work as hard as deliberately, and it will be fairly easy to pull that off. When you have a challenging child, you have to be more intentional and conscious and explicit about, what you're trying to do. Winnicott, who coined the term good enough mother, was a big fan of ordinary parents, ordinary mothers, in the sense that he saw in ordinary parents so many strengths.
对于气质容易、作息规律、顺从、合作、情绪调节良好的孩子来说。我认为亲子关系将具备同样的三个条件，除了包含和引导，但父母不需要那么刻意地努力，这很容易做到。当你有一个具有挑战性的孩子时，你必须更加刻意、自觉和明确地去做你正在尝试的事情。温尼科特（Winnicott）创造了“足够好的母亲”这个词，他是普通父母、普通母亲的忠实拥护者，因为他在普通父母身上看到了许多优点。
And I think our field over time has sort of cast parenting as extraordinary, as something as a separate set of skills that you don't, you're not necessarily equipped with, that you have to go to some book or some expert for, we'd like to believe that if you can manage well your relationships, including the one with your child, you're going to be fine, but recognize that for some children, the task is going to be more challenging, and it's going to look a little different.
我认为随着时间的推移，我们的领域将育儿描绘成非凡的，作为一套独立的技能，你并不一定具备，你必须去查阅某本书或咨询某位专家。我们愿意相信，如果你能很好地处理你的人际关系，包括与孩子的关系，你就会没问题，但要认识到，对于一些孩子来说，这项任务会更具挑战性，看起来也会有所不同。
Let's close with this one question. I'm going to throw it at both of you sequentially, which is for each of you, what is one piece of parenting advice that you would like to leave with our listeners? One of the things that I talk about within the beginning of the book, which when Tim approached me about writing this together, this is the first thing that came to my mind and really stuck with me when I was first learning how to be a clinical psychologist. So I'll give you this antidote and then I'll sort of end with what I mean by it all. So I had a parent come in and she had a young boy and she leaned in close to me when she was trying to seek services and she said, I love my child, but I don't like my child. And it stuck with me for so long and it took a long time for me to connect and understand what that meant finally when I had my own children. But I think the point being here that there are many things that you can. can work on as a parent. We can always do better and seek for more for our children. And yet,
让我们用这个问题来结束。我将依次向你们两位提问，即对于你们每个人来说，有一条您想留给听众的育儿建议是什么？我在书的开头谈到的一件事，当Tim找我一起写这本书时，这是我脑海中浮现的第一件事，当我刚开始学习如何成为一名临床心理学家时，它真的深深印在我的脑海里。所以我给你讲这个轶事，然后我会用我所表达的意思来结束。所以有一位母亲带着她的小男孩进来，当她试图寻求服务时，她凑近我对我说，我爱我的孩子，但我不喜欢我的孩子。这句话在我脑海中停留了很久，直到我自己有了孩子，我才花了很长时间去联系和理解这句话的含义。但我认为重点在于，作为父母，有很多事情你可以努力。我们总是可以做得更好，为我们的孩子寻求更多。然而，
if we can lead with love and if we can remember that at the end of the day, our task is to love our children and be there for them and accept them, I think that is the biggest thing that needs to happen first before you worry about anything else. And so there are many things we want for our children. There are many things we hope for for our children. And if we just can accept them for who they are and where they're at, I think that is the first thing you have to accomplish as a parent before you can try to do anything else. Dr. Cavell? Parenting involves the head and the heart or science and art, if you will. And so some parents sometimes lead too much. much with what's happening emotionally. And some parents are trying to do what the science they
如果我们能以爱为先，如果我们能记住，归根结底，我们的任务是爱我们的孩子，陪伴他们并接纳他们，我认为这是在担心其他任何事情之前最需要发生的事情。所以我们对孩子有很多期望。我们对孩子有很多希望。如果我们能仅仅接纳他们本来的样子和他们所处的阶段，我认为这是作为父母在尝试做任何其他事情之前必须完成的第一件事。Cavell博士？育儿涉及头脑和心灵，或者说是科学和艺术。所以有些父母有时在情感上投入太多。而有些父母正试图做他们认为科学上
think is right. The science tells us this. There are some things that are important and try to emphasize those things. And our book speaks to that. And there are a lot of things that are not, that don't matter that much. And so if you want to use your mind or the science of parenting, recognize that not everything is consequential. In fact, the science of parenting would say to you very strongly. When you go to decide where to put your energies, put it on the relationship. That's where you double down. So if you're trying to decide, should I put my child in time?
正确的事情。科学告诉我们这一点。有些事情很重要，要试着强调这些事情。我们的书也谈到了这一点。有很多事情并不重要，没那么重要。所以如果你想运用你的头脑或育儿科学，要认识到并非所有事情都有后果。事实上，育儿科学会非常强烈地告诉你。当你决定把精力放在哪里时，放在关系上。那是你应该加倍投入的地方。所以如果你在试图决定，我应该让我的孩子暂停活动吗？
Now, should I use a star chart? Should I, you know, take him to a professional? Pay attention to the relationship. Is my relationship with my child healthy? Is it strong? Has it, is it meeting that 80-20 criteria? And if not, what can I do to bolster that relationship? And I offer that because I don't think assessing the quality of the relationship is often what parents typically go to early.
现在，我应该使用星级表吗？我应该，你知道，带他去看专业人士吗？关注关系。我与孩子的关系健康吗？它牢固吗？它是否符合那80-20的标准？如果不是，我能做些什么来加强这种关系？我提出这一点是因为我认为评估关系的质量通常不是父母早期会去考虑的事情。
Instead, they're looking for a quick answer to fix some problem as opposed to saying, how are we doing my child and I? What can I do to make that relationship strong? Maybe do I need to, does it need to be repaired in some way? Am I struggling emotionally to be available and patient with my child? What do I need to do to be an emotional? healthy parents so I can have a better relationship with my child. So it's a different way to think about parenting, not as a job where you look at an endless series of fixes, but it's about a relationship that you manage 18 plus years. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today.
相反，他们是在寻找解决某个问题的快速答案，而不是问，我和我的孩子相处得怎么样？我能做些什么来使这种关系牢固？也许我需要，它需要以某种方式修复吗？我在情感上是否难以做到对孩子有求必应和耐心？我需要做什么才能成为一个情感健康的父母，这样我才能与孩子建立更好的关系？所以这是一种不同的育儿思维方式，不是把它当作一份工作，看着无穷无尽的修复清单，而是关于一种你经营18年以上的关系。好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我。
I think you have provided our listeners with some excellent and sound advice. Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you for having us. And speaking of our listeners, if you would like a copy of good enough parenting, You can visit the book section of our website, www.apa.org, and you can order one there. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckoningof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
我认为你们为我们的听众提供了一些极好且合理的建议。谢谢。不客气。谢谢你们邀请我们。说到我们的听众，如果您想要一本《足够好的育儿》（Good Enough Parenting），您可以访问我们网站的图书部分，www.apa.org，您可以在那里订购。您可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果您喜欢您所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology
at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Kondyenne。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。